euh
moi
étranger
est tombé est
oh
c'est du
plaisir
partout
tu vas
dans ma tête
et tu t'attardes comme une chasse et un refrain
et je te trouve
tourner
dans mon cerveau
comme les bulles
dans une coupe de champagne
tu vas
dans ma tête
comme une gorgée  de pétillant
et je trouve la simple mention de toi
comme
le frisson de la pensée
que tu pourrais penser à ma demande
jette un sort sur moi
encore je me suis dit
prends contact avec toi
c'est est
euh
moi
étranger
je serais  je voudrais d'
abord dire bonjour à mes amis ici en
france
ghee et nicole plugnier
monsieur miss richey
mon équipe de production de jeff godley
p plungier
john eastman
frank chevalier
brandon
nick sandro chris darrow et l'ensemble
implacable 7.
euh oui
mais tu n'as pas besoin de
moi  je ne te suivrai pas
à
moins que je sois là
je
n'ai pas peur
je ne veux pas être ton
seigneur d'armes
oh tu peux me taquiner
oui
j'aimerais
ne m'aime pas
parce que
je n'ai pas
peur je ne  je veux être ton bouc
émissaire
je ne veux pas être
ton bouc émissaire
je ne veux pas être ton arme
ah
oh
je ne veux pas être toi
je ne veux pas être vieux
je ne veux pas être tes
armes
eh bien
ça dit que tu n'as pas à me jouer à l'
envers
existe
désolé
tu n'as pas à me jouer à l'envers
pour comprendre le sens de mon couplet
tu n'as pas besoin de mourir et d'aller en enfer je
ressens
la malédiction du diable
je pensais que ma vie était une photo sur
les cartes de noël de la famille
les images ont-elles commencé à  fondu
je suis
c'est un
sacrifice une église vide le doux
petit bébé s'est levé un homme dans la masse du
mexique
et je n'ai pas d'endroit où courir
payer pour la protection
traquer les
souvenirs
ne pas avoir à me jouer à l'envers pour obtenir
le sens de mon verset  tu n'as pas
à mourir et
mon enfance
j'ai
entendu vu au
plus profond d'en bas
venir autour de toi
écouter entendre l'appel
voir l'écriture sur le mur
taper dans tes mains tenir ta tête
fermer les yeux tu vois rouge
ne peux pas
voir les couleurs  voir les lignes
reculer loin derrière
rester immobile
tout l'amour et tout le monde qui
tourne pour euh
est
et tout l'amour dans tout le monde
ça tourne pour toi et moi
yay
étranger
un
moi me
vois
étranger
canada
alors
donc la
chine rentre
à la maison sait juste
embrasse moi
hé
c'est
mon
bas
alors ne t'inquiète pas
je suis un homme d'âme
oh
je suis un soul man
alors
oh
car
si
étranger
dans
mon
est
étranger
moi
homme
siri
moi
toi